I recently saw a post from a friend that
mentioned they had pre-ordered a bunch
of cards for the latest set because the
magic bug had bitten them hard so it got
me thinking what are the best cards for
beginners and newcomers to pick up on
launch day of the most recent set let's
go over that list together now we don't
muck around here on Attack on cardboard
so we're starting at number one the best
card you can buy on launch day
is nothing there are no cards you should
be buying on launch Day Ever if you are
someone who is playing Magic casually
and not at a competitive level do
yourself and your wallet a favor and do
not buy or pre-order cards for the
latest set on launch day let's take a
look at this example Elish Noor mother
of machines one of the top Chase mythics
for 2023 at just around all willb one's
launch date ellish was sitting at about
only one month later the market price
for Elish was around
$33 so simply just waiting a month saved
you $10 whole doar and if you could just
wait 6 months more by the time Wilds
ofel drain released ellish was down to
$20 which is where the card seems to
have stabilized at a massive
55% decrease in price now okay that's a
card that was released over a year ago
let's look at something a little bit
more recent the last standard set of
2023 lost Cavs of Exelon oja T deepest
Foundation the creature token tripler it
was pre-selling from anywhere between 30
and
$48 the card launched with a price of
$28 and only 3 months later the current
market price is
$17 a nearly 40% drop in price goter
stamped Tyrant well some poor bugger
pre-ordered it at 75 bucks it launched
at around 20 and will now only run you
about $15 a 25% drop bone hard Draco is
an interesting one it launched at about
$15 2 weeks later it was at $25 and now
it's sitting about 10 bucks again the
point being save yourself some money and
do not pre-order cards do not fomo buy
them on launch today just be a cool
cucumber and play the waiting game now
don't get me wrong there are certainly
some instances where a card will Spike
after launch shrid the apocalypse is the
perfect example originally launching at
around
$35 just a few days later she was at 50
sh old found herself in a number of
powerful decks across standard Pioneer
and Commander and this has given her a
steady price increase over the last 2
years years and now a copy of shrid can
set you back nearly
$80 but that is just one card out of
248 nearly every other card in the set
dipped significantly in price after just
a few months currently the chase Mythic
for mkm is dely StreetWise Lookout at
the time of recording the market price
for dely is about 20 bucks but I think
we've got another ellish Noor on our
hands here unless dely finds a solid
home in standard or Pioneer it shouldn't
be too long before they drop in price to
something a little bit more affordable
of course I could be completely wrong
but time and time again price drops
happen across 90% of cards in a set only
a few months after launch and with the
amount of sets Wizards is currently
releasing consumers quickly forget about
previous cards and move on to the next
thing helping the price drop drops even
more again unless you're playing
competitively and grinding the rcq do
yourself and your wallet a favor and
don't buy singles on launch
day so what do you think is the most
overhyped card of the current set let me
know in the comments down below be sure
to like the video If you learned
something and be sure to subscribe if
you somehow always manage to buy cards
at their Peak price right before it
crashes is thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one